since you mentioned there's a kind of
drift as you write about in the book and
you mentioned now there's a drift
towards the left in Academia which would
also maybe draw a distinction here
between the left and the right and the
cancel culture as you present in your
book sure is not necessarily associated
with any one political Viewpoint that
there's mechanisms on both sides that
result in cancellation and censorship in
violation of freedom of speech so one
thing I want to be really clear about is
the book takes on both right and left
cancer culture they're different in a
lot of ways and definitely you know
Council culture from the left is more
important in Academia where the left is
dominates but we talk a lot about cancel
culture coming from legislatures we talk
a lot about Council culture on campus as
well because even though
um most of the attempts that come from
on campus to get People canceled are
still from the left there are a lot of
attacks that come from the right that
come from you know uh attempts by
different organizations and sometimes
when there are stories in Fox News you
know like they'll go after professors
and about one-third of the attempts to
get professors punished that are
successful actually do come from the
right and and we talk about attempts to
get Books banned um in in the in the
book we talk about
um and uh talk about suing the Florida
legislature Ron DeSantis had something
called the stop woke act which we told
everyone this is laughably
unconstitutional
um they tried to ban you know particular
Topics in higher ed and we're like no
this is a joke like like this will this
will be laughed out of court
um and they didn't listen to us and they
brought it they passed it and we sued
and we won now they're trying again with
something that's equally as
unconstitutional and we will sue again
and we will and we will win can you
elaborate and stop woke X this is
presumably trying to limit certain
topics from being taught in school yeah
it basically woke up effects um you know
it's more it came out of the sort of
attempt to get at a critical race Theory
um so it's topics related to race gender
Etc
um I don't remember exactly how they
tried to Cabinet to um uh to CRT
um but when you actually the law is
really well established that you can't
tell higher education what they're
allowed to teach without violating uh
without violating the First Amendment
and when this got in front of a judge it
was exactly as uh he was exactly as uh
skeptical of it as we thought he'd be I
think he called this dystopian
um and it wasn't a close call so if
you're against that kind of teaching the
right way to fight it is by making the
case that it's not a good idea as part
of the curriculum as opposed to Banning
it from the creative yeah it just the
state doesn't have the power to Simply
say to ban
um you know what what teacher what
professors in higher education teach now
it gets a little more complicated when
you talk about K-12 because the state
has a role in deciding what public K-12
teaches because they're your kids they
it's taxpayer funded and generally the
legislature is involved there is
democratic oversight of that process so
for K-12 is there also lean towards the
left in terms of the administration that
manages the curriculum yeah um there
there definitely is
um in K-12 the the I mean my kids go to
public school
um I have a five and a seven year old uh
and they have lovely teachers
um but we have run into a lot of
problems with with education schools
that fire
um and a lot of the graduates of
Education school end up being the
administrators who clamp down on Free
Speech in higher education
and so I've been trying to think of
positive ways to take on some of the
some of the problems that I see in K-12
I thought that the attempt to just
dictate you you won't teach the
following 10 books you know or 20 books
or 200 books was the wrong way to do it
now when it comes to deciding what books
are in the curriculum again that's
something the legislature actually you
know can have some say in and that's
pretty uncontroversial um in terms of
the law but when it comes to how you
fight it I had something that since I'm
kind of stuck with the formula I called
empowering of the American mind I gave
principles that were inconsistent
um with the sort of group think and
heavy emphasis on uh identity politics
uh that
um you know some of the critics are
rightfully complaining about in K-12 uh
and we we that is actually in canceling
of the American mind but I have a more
detailed explanation of it that I'm
going to be putting up on my blog the
eternally radical idea is it possible to
legally that's just a silly question
perhaps create an extra protection for
certain kinds of literature 1984 or
something to remain in the curriculum I
mean it's already it's all protected I
guess yeah I I guess to protect against
administrators from fiddling too much
with the curriculum like stabilizing the
curriculum I don't I don't know what the
Machinery of the K-12 Public School in
K-12 you know the state legislatures you
know um they're part of that they're
part of that and they can say like you
should teach the following books right
now of course people are always a little
bit worried that um if you uh if they
were to recommend you know teach uh
teach the Declaration of Independence
you know that it will end up being well
they're going to teach the Declaration
of Independence was just to protect
slavery which yeah it wasn't yeah so
teaching a particular topic matters
which textbooks you choose which
perspective you take all that kind of
stuff yes there's like religion starts
to creep into the whole question of like
how you know is the Bible are you
allowed to teach into incorporate that
into education uh don't yeah I mean mean
I'm I'm an atheist uh with an intense
interest in religion I actually read the
entire Bible this year just because I do
stuff like that and I never actually had
read it begin from beginning to end um
then I read the Quran because you know
and I'm going to try to do the Book of
Mormon but you know well they started
hey you're so fascinating
um do you recommend doing that I think
you should
um just to know because it's such a
touchstone
um in in the way people talk about
things it can get pretty tedious but I
even made myself read through all of the
very specific instructions on how tall
the different parts of the temple need
to be and how long the garbs need to be
and what shape they need to be and what
like and those go on a lot
um there that surprisingly surprisingly
big chunk of Exodus
um I thought that was more like in
Leviticus and Deuteronomy
um but then you get to books like job
you know wow I mean job is such a read
and no way job originally had that
ending like job is basically you it
starts out as this perverse bet between
god
um and Satan about whether or not they
can actually make a good man renounce
God and initially they can't it's all
going very predictably and then they
finally really tortured job
and he turns into the best
why is God cruel how could God possibly
exist How could a kind God do these
things and he beats he turns into like
the best lawyer in the entire world and
he defeats everyone all the people who
come to argue with him he he argues the
pants off of them and then suddenly at
the end God shows up and he's like
um well you know uh I am everywhere and
uh it's a very confusing answer he gives
an answer kind of like I am there when
when when lionesses give birth and I am
there and by the way there's this giant
monster Leviathan that's very big and
it's very scary and I and I have to
manage the universe and I'm kind of like
God are you saying that you're very busy
is that it it it it is that essentially
your argument to job and you don't
mention the whole you don't mention the
whole kind of like that I I have a bet
that's why I was torturing you that
doesn't come up and then at the end he
decided God decides like job's like Oh
no you're totally right I was totally
wrong uh sorry
um and I and God says I'm gonna punish
those people who tried to argue with you
and didn't didn't win so
um so he gets rid of the I don't know
exactly what he does to them I don't
remember
um and then he gives job all his money
back and all and it makes him super
prosperous and I'm like no way that was
the original ending of that book like
because this would like this was clearly
loved novel that they were like but I
can't have that ending ending okay so so
yeah so it's a long way of saying I
actually think it's worthwhile uh some
of it was you're always kind of
surprised when you end up in the part
like um
there are parts of it that will sneak up
on you kind of like Isaiah has a trip
um Ecclesiastes Depeche Mode